un enfant se projettera mieux sur une
poupée qui aura qui ne sera pas
perfectionner dans tous ses détails
parce qu'à ce moment là on peut dire que
le jouet clos qu'il n'y a plus rien à
imaginer pareille certaines poupées et
certains sources peuvent même être
dangereux en particulier si leur taille
est trop grande par rapport à celle de
l'enfant est ce que ce texte dangereux
je le pense je le crois quelquefois mais
en tout cas il arrive que des enfants
arrivent à s'en défendre tout seul en
les utilisant pas et en les laissant de
côté mais quelquefois ils s'en servent
et cela peut être nocif parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à le dominer il faut
qu'un enfant surtout quand vous offrez
une poupée et un ours c'est en général
un enfant relativement en bas âge
et si un enfant ne peut pas le dominer
ne peut pas l'introduire dans son monde
imaginaire ce jouet est mauvais parce
que ce jouet peut lui faire peur parce
que ce jouet peut peut être représenté
pour lui quelque chose qui est mort en
fait quelque chose qui est trop grand
qui est terrifiant qu'ils apportent la
mort qui est déjà mort
si vous offrez un jouet très cher vous
imiter une charge affective énorme parce
que tout de même il représente par
rapport à ce que vous gagnez vous pouvez
tout à fait bloqué là aussi se jouer en
empêchant l'enfant de s'en servir parce
qu'il sera culpabiliser si la bim
je pense qu'une bonne poupée n'est pas
forcément une poupée qui fait quelque
chose une bonne poupée est une poupée
sur laquelle on à qui on peut faire
faire imaginer qu'elle fait tout ce que
fait un bébé
certains parents qui ont peur de donner
à leurs enfants des jouets guerriers des
armes des pistolets et des revolvers
esquissé mauvais si je vous dis agressif
ce n'est pas parce que vous donnez des
armes un enfant qu'il est agressif s'il
a besoin d'armes c'est parce qu'il a
besoin de manifester cette agressivité
et les panoplies pourquoi pas tout ce
qui permet de se déguiser mais encore
une fois les enfants c'est existe fort
bien avec tout autre chose que des
panoplies encore qu'une panoplie ne soit
pas vain ça n'est ni bon ni mauvais je
crois que ce qui est bon ou mauvais
c'est de savoir écouter un enfant pour
savoir au moment voulu ce dont il a
besoin et ce dont il a envie